So we're,
we're thrilled this afternoon to welcome
Dr. Rose Mcdermott to the talks at
Google program.
Now,
it's no question that politics is on the
forefront of people's minds these days.
Um, Doctor Mcdermott a discusses her
latest findings from our research and the
effects of biology on political attitudes,
preferences and behavior.
Please join me in welcoming.
I'm rose to Google. Thank you.
Thank you very much for taking
your time out to come and, um, uh,
have our chat today about
genetics and politics. And, um,
I was just mentioning to Margaret Levy,
the director of the center
that the theatrical piece
of the whole election thing
has been really dramatic.
I really didn't know which part of
it to pay attention to yesterday. So,
um, uh, we'll leave lots of
time to chat about it. But, um,
what I want to do is run through a little
bit of the work that we've been doing
on the genetic foundations of politics
and why that's interesting and different
and important is that for
the last 50 or so years,
really since the start of people
investigating political ideology from the
perspective of political science,
the notion has always been that, um,
these things are socialized, that you
learn them at the feet of your parents,
that you are,
you know,
at the knee of your father and you
love your father and your father's a
Republican. And so then you come
to love the Republican Party.
So it has some kind of affective
part and emotional part,
but also a part that's really about your
education and your family experience,
but not something that's instantiated
in any kind of biological sense.
Um,
and in the last decade or so myself and
concert with my primary collaborator on
this work,
Pita Tommy,
who's at Penn state and a few other
people have been working to start to
investigate the extent to which some of
these questions of political ideology
may actually be instantiated, uh,
biologically and genetically. Um,
and this work really a dates to a seminal
piece that Nick Martin and Linda Neves
did in 1986 in the proceedings of
the National Academy of Sciences.
And Linden is a very
interesting guy. He's a, um,
he's an ordained minister
in the Anglican Church,
but he's also the father of
behavior genetics and a lot
of really important ways.
Um,
and what happened up until that time is
that everybody looking at genetics was
really looking at things like disease
processes and social attitudes was always
the control.
It was the thing that everybody knew.
It had nothing to do with genetics
and nothing to do with biology.
And what they were able to show in this
original piece is that it's not the
control that actually you
see bigger effects on some
of the social and political
attitudes.
Then you even do on disease processes.
So how you do these studies with twins,
right?
So you look at the difference between
identical twins and fraternal twins and
identical twins are basically same person
genetically that just happened to be
born in two different bodies.
And fraternal twins are
like any other sibling set.
It's just that they're
born at the same time.
And because of the mathematical way you
can traction that you can analyze the
extent to which these
attitudes, um, our genetic,
I'm not just attitudes, but
social behaviors, disease
processes, whatever it is,
shared family and shared family or things
that you share, not just your family,
but education and other kinds of social
processes and unique environment,
which is the thing that
only happens to you.
What's important about unique environment
though is that some of those processes
are also biological.
So for example,
the in utero bath in which you
just state is a unique environment.
It's got some biological elements to it,
but it only happens to you of course,
unless you're a twin. So when you look at
this, um, the way that this is measured,
and this is what this graph is here is
the Wilson Patterson scale and it looks,
it's the way that genetics as
opposed to political science,
people look at attitudes and it just
has a bunch of words, different topics,
the draft, you know, gun control, things
like that. And people just respond,
yes, no, or I don't
know, which is immediate.
Usually there's about a 38 items and
you can then traction what percentage of
them can be attributable to genetic
versus environmental factors.
And when they originally did
this work in [inaudible] 86,
almost half of the contribution
to people's attitudes
came from these additive
genetic factors.
So when later on,
some number of years later when Peta,
Tommy and I started looking at this,
we broke it up not just by
overall liberal and conservatism,
which is how the original work was done,
but to actually look at specific things
from political party identification to
political knowledge and so on.
And in this graph you can see the
blue part is the part that's genetic.
That green part is the part that's
kind of unique environment. Uh,
the orange part is the sort of shared
environment and you can see it really
differs by per particular topic.
Um,
one of the interesting things about
this is what it shows is that political
ideology, like, you know, um, liberal
to conservative in a world scale.
Think about it. Communists
versus fascists, not just
Democrat and Republican, um,
is highly genetic. It's got a
very large genetic contribution.
Whereas political party identification,
Republican,
Democrat actually has very low genetic
contribution. And we can talk about um,
uh, why and how that works in and how
it's different if you're interested, uh,
in the Q and. A. So the question becomes,
is there a real difference between not
just people but politicians on the right
and the left.
And so I just want to have you take a
look at some of these images because I
fundamentally believe that some of
the differences are embodied that they
actually have sort of
physical elements. So, um,
and you can see some of them in
the expressions that typical,
these are all the official, uh,
photographs that people have.
So in the United Kingdom,
this is Theresa May on the left,
Boris Johnson on the right,
you can see in France Marine Le Pen who
may or may not win the French elections
on the right. Depends I guess on
the Russian hacking. Um, and uh, uh,
Halon two's has the lowest approval
rating ever in the history of the French
republic on the left.
And of course our classic
last series of elections.
You can see how those things
work. Um, so there's some,
there's different ways in which you
can measure physical end genetic
contributions.
Obviously I've shown you,
I described a bit about how that happens
genetically in how you look at it at
twins, but there's other ways
you can look at it as well. Um,
this study which was done by Daren
Schriber when he was at San Diego, um,
was trying to look at the way in which,
um,
MRI technology and looking
at brain activation patterns
can help you distinguish
people on the right
and people on the left.
What was interesting about this study
is that the gold standard in political
science about telling whether somebody
is a Democrat or Republican is just to
ask them, right? Like are you on
the right or are you on the left?
And then they tell you and then you see
whether or not they vote consistently.
With that,
using this MRI technology,
he was actually better able to
predict how people would vote then,
then telling him.
And what was particularly interesting
is that people on the left had a lot of
activation in a part of the
brain that you see here,
which is the insula that's
associated, uh, with uh,
feelings of disgust and people on the
right had a lot of activation in the
Amygdala, which is associated
with feelings of fear, um,
by and large emotional activation
in general, but fear in particular.
So another way you can measure them
is with skin conductance response.
This is actually Matt Hibbings hand.
This is from a series of experiments
that John Hibbing did in Nebraska using
physiological measures.
And what you can see with what they
do here in these studies is they show
reactivity to particular images.
I'll show you what those
images look like in a second,
but you can show that people who are on
the right have much more activation to
threatening stimuli.
And that's basically what you see here.
So what is threatening stimuli
look like? Oh, sorry, this,
this is what threatening stimuli it
looks like, right? So you can see,
and there's positive images too.
You can see they show images of like
bunnies in the fields and you know,
little kids, um, and flowers and
kittens and things like that,
but also quite threatening stimuli.
And what you can do using eye tracking
technology and we've been doing that is
to look at the ways in which people
look at different parts of these images.
Now the reason that is interesting and
important is that a lot of discussion
about politics is about how,
okay,
we have the same experience but we
differ in our interpretation of it.
And with the eye tracking
technology shows you is that,
that's not entirely the case.
We may differ in our interpretation,
but we also differ in what
we experienced perceptually.
So what we pay attention to as somebody
on the right or as somebody on the left
is literally different. And I'd like
to show you some examples of that.
So what you see here, the red dots are
where on average these are um, you know,
aggregated findings. What people on
the right are paying attention to.
And the blue ones are what people on
the left are paying attention to. Um,
what you see here is that what people
on the right are paying attention to is
what the spider,
they're paying attention to the
threat they're paying attention to.
You know what the concern is,
whereas differentially people on the
left are paying attention to eyes.
Liberals love eyes.
If you ever do eye tracking technology,
what liberals are paying
attention to our eyes,
they really want to know what people are
feeling and the best way to know what,
how people are feeling. You think
it's the mouth, it's not the mouth,
it's the eyes.
So that's what's going on here.
And you can do it across many domains.
It doesn't just have to do
with fear and threat domains.
You can also do it with sexual domains.
So you can see here what I love about
this is liberals are all paying attention
to the jewelry and the hair, right? Like,
oh, I sort of like that necklace and she,
how does she do her hair?
Right?
And what are the people on the right
paying attention to the boobs and the lick
la lip lock, right? Like, it's all
about, um, a particular kind of, um,
sexual, um, whether you want to construct
it as threat or opportunity, you know,
however it is, there's really different
ways in which they're paying attention.
So it's not just that people are
differing in their interpretation,
they're actually experiencing
different, um, uh,
perceptual realities both visually and
auditorily. You can show this with, uh,
we've done experiments where we've also
had different narrations associated with
these stories and you get
people responding to different
parts of what they hear
as well. Um, and there's interesting
and important sex differences.
Men tend to respond much more
to the visual part in women,
much more to the auditory part. So, um,
there's other differences as
well as ideological ones. So, um,
this shows you that there can be
political, um, uh, associations with this.
The darker colors are where people are
spending more time looking at the image.
So this is a man, he's got a cane,
obviously the cops and the gun, right?
So what happens is that conservatives
tend to pay much more attention to symbols
of authority, the badge of the gun, things
like that. Whereas the liberals are,
again, not only paying attention
to the eyes, but if you look at it,
they're also paying much more attention
to the cane, right? So they're,
they're literally literally experiencing
different aspects of these images.
When you cross these images
with particular kinds of
political attitudes and
behavior,
you can see that the kinds of things
people are paying attention to actually
affects or is affected by
or most likely both, um,
their attitudes around certain things.
So this image is actually,
you can't see the back part of the image,
but these are guys around a coffin.
So they're looking at a coffin.
And as I mentioned,
we had these different stories,
these different auditory stories and in
one story we told them that this person
had died in combat and another story
we told them that the person had been a
looter who had been shot that had been
looting a important archaeological
treasures. And you can see that
between liberals and conservatives,
it doesn't really affect how much time
they spend looking at this part of the
image of people saluting it,
whether or not you know how the story is,
but it really does affect the Luder if
you tell them that there are Luder, right?
So if you tell them they died in combat,
both liberals and conservatives respond
similarly. If you say it's a looter,
the conservatives are going to be spending
much more time looking at that part
of the image of the solute
than the liberals are.
You can also cross it the other way with
the image I just showed you of the cops
with the man on the ground where you can
describe it as either a beat down or an
arrest.
And again,
you get different levels of how much
time people are spending looking at the
cane. Um, depending on what
kind of story you tell.
Yeah.
Uh, this also happens as I
mentioned with sex differences.
You can see male versus female spending
time looking at the necklace, uh, in the,
in the Madonna and Britney Spears one.
But this other image which
is a woman actually, um,
somebody dressed in combat fatigues
holding an injured child and you can see
that men and women are spending different
times looking at the child's face
versus a child's body
as well. Um, so you can,
you can look at these things both
from the perspective of ideology,
sex differences.
You could do it any way you want.
You can do it with religion or any
other kind of identity that you want.
These things then also predict
policy preferences. So when you look,
have people look at images of soldiers
saluting a flag and then ask questions
about did the u s make a mistake
about sending troops into Iraq?
You can actually predict their response
based on how much time they spend
looking at the flag versus how much time
they spend looking at other parts of
the image.
So that those spending much more time
looking at the flag are those who are
going to say, no, we didn't. We
didn't make a mistake going into Iraq.
And the other image,
you can also look at,
ask people about whether or not they think
we're gonna this was done a few years
ago before I'm the u s pulled
out of Iraq, um, candy.
Or will they win the war in Iraq?
And depending on how much time they
spend looking at the tanks as opposed to
looking at the sheep, you
can actually predict, again,
whether or not they think
victory is going to be possible.
So these are various ways in
which you can measure and look at,
um, uh, biological and
physiological contributions to,
um, uh, political ideology.
But then the question becomes
a web part of it is genetic.
Okay.
So one of the things that drives me
crazy when I watched the news is that
they're always talking about how,
uh,
researchers find the liberal gene or the
gene or the gene for fear or the gene
for blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. And what's important
to understand is that, um,
there is no such thing,
right?
There's never going to be a gene for
these are very, very complex processes.
They involve many,
many,
many genetic factors in interaction
with environmental factors and um,
they happen across developmental pathways
based on like what happened to you as
a kid,
what happened to you in the moment.
And so it's never going to be that there's
a gene for it's much more complicated.
And if I have one take home
message, that's it. But if we have,
um,
if in fact the story I'm telling you based
on the data I have is true and a very
large percentage of our
political ideology is heritable,
then the most important choice you make
and your children in determining your
children's a political ideology
is your choice of mate.
So that brings us back to how
mating actually contributes
to the development and
polarization of politics over time.
And that's what I want to spend a little
bit of time talking about before having
a conversation with you. So this is
obviously a very complicated slide,
but I just wanted to sh to show that
there's many things that contribute to an
outcome. It's not right a gene for,
but we have developmental issues,
we have physiological issues,
we have lots of other things
going on in development.
But what I'm going to have pay
attention to right now is this issue of
individual DNA.
How your individual Dna from your parents
meeting and mating determines not only
you,
but how your individual meeting may
affect your children's political ideology
and other characteristics.
So the classic work on mate selection,
which again was done from a,
you know,
a socialization perspective
by David Buss in Seventies.
I'm looked at as people, basically
what the characteristics were that, um,
and these were done in
strait population's,
remember this was done in
the seventies before. Um,
there was quite as much
attention to homosexual meeting,
but this was really about
heterosexual meeting because, um,
we were really looking at, at children.
So, um, when he looked at them,
you can see there's a lot of overlap
between what males and females say that
they want.
Um,
the ones in Italics are the ones where
it's statistically different in how
important those characteristics are to
them. Although this was done in the 70s,
recent studies are very, very,
very similar with one exception,
which is that now men really care a lot
more about how much money their female
counterparts make.
So that's becomes a much more important
than physical attractiveness and recent
studies, uh, in, um, male meeting.
So that's the only part in which is
really significantly different than it was
in the 70s.
So one of the studies we did is we
went through an online dating site.
I actually did this myself.
I can't say what the site was,
but I can say it was the
single most depressing thing
I've ever done in my life.
And,
um,
we took 313 zip codes and we took the
first five men in the first five women.
And, um, we looked at
how their profiles were.
So what did they say they care about? Did
they say they care about politics? Um,
did they say that it mattered and so on.
And what we found is that people are much
more likely to say that they were fat
then, that they had a
political preference. Right?
So this is the woody Allen line about
how you're trying to double your chances
for a date on a Saturday night.
By not saying I'm only going to date
a Republican, or I'm only gonna date,
you know,
a Democrat or whatever it happens to be.
But the reason that's important is that
people are wrong about what matters in
their meat choices.
So they think that what matters is that
they share interests like going to the
movies or going to the beach. But if you
look at what happens in longterm mating,
what holds people together, that's
not it. So then the question becomes,
is it really about politics? And I
want to show you some data about this.
People think that what happens is that
over time people converge that they're
starting to become more similar in
politics over time. And in fact,
that's not the case. What you get is
as sortation not convergence there,
they're meeting and meeting and matching
up with the people who share their
political ideology. They're not
becoming more similar over time.
And we know this from longterm studies,
these look at people before marriage
and about 10 years after marriage.
And you can see that the statistical
associations don't change very much.
What does change is how you look.
So people start to look much
more like their spouses.
So if you have pictures of people when
they get married and then 10 years later
and you have independent coders, they'll
say at the beginning, you know, oh,
these people don't look at all alike.
And then 10 years later they'll say,
these people are brother and sister.
They're there physically related.
They're not spouses. And it's because
you mimic each other's facial expression.
It changes the way that the
blood flow works in your face.
And you start to look alike.
So don't marry somebody you don't find
attractive because you look like them, uh,
over time.
Um,
so it's not actually the case
that you have a sortation,
you have this convergence.
So the question is if you,
if you don't know that you're looking
for somebody in the same politics,
right?
You think that what you're looking for
is somebody who likes movies that you
like, but in fact the people that you're
actually marrying as opposed to dating,
but actually marrying and having kids
with are the same than what's happening.
It's not actually an issue of selection.
It's an issue of d selection.
Your d selecting the people who don't
share your basic fundamental political
values.
When you look at the things that people
who are in longterm marriages actually
correlate with anything
more than a random chance,
there's only three things.
Religion,
which we know is actually him
off lists on socialization.
So what I mean by that is it is a
socialized thing where you're basically
meeting and marrying people in
your same social network of six,
share your same religious orientation,
whether that's being an atheist
or whether it's being a Jewish,
whether it's being a Muslim, whatever
it is, politics and drinking frequency,
whether you're a teetotaler, whether
you're an alcoholic, everything else,
all the things that you think
matter, whether it's you
know, your ideal body type,
how much people sleep,
extroversion, introversion,
it's less than would be
expected by tossing a coin.
And these are really longterm
marriages, right? 30 years or more.
There's one exception to this
and that has to do with race.
This is of course an American sample.
And so it's hard to say whether
or not this is true outside race,
but what you do get is that conservatives
are much less likely to be willing to
marry outside their race.
And what's really driving this
is conservative white men.
So conservative white men really don't
like to marry outside their race.
And that's really what's driving this.
But that's the one exception to this, uh,
earlier.
Larger generalization.
Now from an evolutionary standpoint,
if you think that some of this
is genetically instantiated,
and I believe that the data suggests that,
well it doesn't just suggests that,
but really demonstrates that what
happens is that over many generations you
would expect more political polarization.
And by that I mean as liberals,
Mary Liberals,
as Conservatives and Mary conservatives,
they're much more likely to have
children have those same dispositions.
Now a hundred years ago,
it didn't matter so much because what
was happening then is that we're wealthy
men were marrying
beautiful women on average.
So the political ideology of the woman
wasn't as important to the meat choice.
But now as marriage has
become a luxury good, right?
Marriage is actually one of those things
that's more bifurcated by class now,
then, um, money was by race in the 1950s.
So there's two sets of people, right?
There's people who get married,
have kids engage in the
intergenerational transfer of wealth,
and then there's people who have kids
never get married and never have any
wealth to pass along to their children.
But those who actually get married
and have children in this kind of way,
in this sort of, um, you
know, uh, bifurcated way,
you're getting a pulling
apart of ideology, right?
You're getting a pulling apart where
liberals are marrying liberals,
conservatives or Marin conservatives,
they're having children who
are disproportionally that
way cause it's not random
anymore.
And so you get increasing polarization.
It doesn't take as many
generations as you might think.
And I think that's why we're
seeing at least in part,
increasing political polarization over
what may have happened in Saint 1950.
So as I mentioned,
if what's going on is that longterm
mates actually select each other based on
political ideology. But people don't
know that they're doing that, right?
Because when they write their
online profiles, they don't say,
I'm unwilling to marry a
Democrat on average. Um,
then what's happening is d selection.
But if you don't know it,
it means it's happening unconsciously.
So the question is how is that
happening and our solution,
our suggestion was that it happened
through smell, through pheromones.
And that was the experimental
tests that we ran on this.
What made us think about this was actually
running genome wide association tests
on political and looking at those aspects
of the chromosome that appeared to be
most related to political ideology.
So when you do these tests,
those that are considered suggestive are
those that are like two times 10 to the
eighth,
whereas those that are
considered significant are
three times 10 to the eighth.
And if you look at those
factors that cross those,
those thresholds of suggestion or
significance with regard to political
ideology, every single one in the miss
somehow related to olfaction to smell in a
disproportionate way that explains a lot,
right,
explains how it is that people
know this automatically,
how their d selecting and how they're
not conscious about that selection.
So we ran a study on this. This
is actually done at Harvard, um,
and we actually did it
not just on em, um, smell,
but we also did it on voice and on,
um, facial similarity and so on.
Um, but our notion was that
political ideology probably
worked on pheromones very
similar to the way that the
immune system works on pheromones.
So we know there's a lot of data showing
that, for example, people actually, um,
find those whose immune system functions
differently than there's much, much,
much more attractive than
those whose ideology. I mean,
whose immune system is the same that
works through pheromones, not conscious,
automatic,
but definitely matters because if you
have children with someone whose immune
system is similar to your own,
they're not going to be as protected
from as many sets of pathogens as people
who are different. So we thought that
political ideology work the same way,
but in a different sense in that you're
attracted to those whose ideologies this
is the same rather than people
whose ideology is different. So,
um, we took 190 people, we took a bunch
of studies on personality, politics,
lifestyle and so on. Um,
and then, um, had the,
found a bunch of people
who had extreme ideology.
They're liberal or conservative.
It's hard in Massachusetts to
find extreme conservatives,
but we shook some trees and found a few
of them and they come into the lab and
you give them, you know, fragrance free
shampoo and fragrance free, um, you know,
soap and everything and you ask them
to take a shower with all this stuff.
And then they were gauze pads under there,
under arms for 24 hours.
And you ask them, you know, they
could exercise and whatever,
but not teed certain kinds of foods,
not to wear certain kinds of perfume,
not to be around scented candles,
not to sleep in a bed with
another person or an animal.
And they do that for 24 hours for
$20, which is unbelievable. Um,
but they do do it.
Um,
and then they come in the next day
and they give you these samples.
And so then what we do is we take these
samples and we have about, you know,
an additional hundred 90
people smell those samples. Um,
and then ask them questions about how
they feel about these samples. You know,
do you think this person is,
um, you know, trustworthy?
Do you think this person is intelligent?
Do you think this person is, you know, um,
a kind. And then we asked them, can you
get this person's political ideology?
And then we ask them,
do you find this person attractive?
And what's amazing about the results
where it came out the way I expect it,
which was surprising.
Um,
and what we found was none of the things
about intelligence or respect or any of
those kinds of things ended
up at all significant.
What was absolutely significant is
how attractive they found people.
So they found those who shared their
political ideology much more attractive
than those who didn't. But they were
wrong about guessing their ideology.
So when you said, do you know
that, let's say you're a liberal,
do you know what this person is completely
random in their assessment of whether
or not that person is
liberal or conservative.
But if you look at whether or not
they find that person attractive,
you can absolutely predict it back.
So it was one of these really funny
studies where it's so wacky that no one
believed it would work.
I wasn't even sure it would work.
And so the first day we did, um, my, uh,
really amazing statistical guy
who's at Harvard, it was like,
this isn't going to work.
And he opens the first vial and he smells
it and he gets sick. Like he's like,
oh, I can't do this. Like this
study isn't going to work.
And I picked it up and I smelled it and
I didn't smell thing. And I thought, Ooh.
And so I called over the lab manager
and I said, Sarah, what do you smell?
And she said, I don't smell a thing.
She was like, let me get my boyfriend.
So she gets her boyfriend from the back
and he smells it and he literally threw
up. He was like, that's
the most disgusting thing
I've ever heard of my life.
And I was like, this is really gonna
work. And what happened was that those,
the person we were smelling
was a conservative guy and
both of them were liberal
guys.
And so it was a really different reaction.
And the last day of the study was
really interesting because, um,
I was running all the subjects and this
guy came in probably the second to the
last person and he said, um,
one of your samples is rancid,
you know, it's really gone bad, you can't,
um, use these samples anymore. And I said,
oh, that's really interesting. You know,
which one is it gave me the number,
you know, 190 ever a time. 190. Thank
you very much. He leaves in the next one,
the next person who comes in
as a young woman and she says,
what are you going to do with the
vials when you're done? And I said,
I'm going to put them in the freezer
and then I'm going to do a molecular
analysis of the DNA that's contained
in the sweat. Are you sure? Yeah,
I'm pretty sure why. Well, you
have to for each one. And I did,
it was like a right arm and a left arm,
right? And I said yes. And she's like,
you don't need both of them. You can do an
analysis on just one. Right. And I said,
yeah, I said, why? She said, can
I take one of them home with me?
And I was like, no, you can't
take one of them home with you.
And when I asked her which one it was,
it was the exact same one that the guy
before had just told me it was rancid.
It was 190 right. And again,
conservative guy, conservative woman,
liberal guy who had come in.
Um, so, well you can see here,
and this looks a little backwards.
This is how it conservative
feels smelling a conservative,
how conservative feel smelling a liberal,
how men feel,
smelling women, how men feel,
smelling, sorry. Men feel smelling men.
Men feel smelling women while you'll see
is women hate the smell of each other,
right? Men really kind of liked
the smell of each other. Um,
conservatives, uh, really like
the smell of other conservatives.
Liberals like the smell of liberals.
Conservatives don't mind.
The smell of liberal says quite
as much when you do it on voice,
what you find is the other asymmetry.
So liberals hate the sound of conservative
voices more than conservatives hate
the sound of liberal voices. So you get
some differences on the voices as well.
So why does it matter? Is is
that, um, attitudes aren't
just attitudes, right? Um,
spouses, a sword on it. People
pass this onto their children. Um,
these differences are partly genetic,
but partly environmental. Um,
and we differ in the way that
we experience these things.
And it doesn't just matter for politics,
it matters for things that are much more
important, much more important, but,
but important in wider parts of the world
rather than just who runs the Horse,
who wins the horse race of the election.
And so I want to talk for just a
minute about one of those applications,
which I'm most interested in,
which has to do with processes of violence
and how attitudes affect processes of
violence. So we see them all over
the world, right? Right now the big,
the big stories are from Syria,
but it's kind of, you know,
eternal wherever it happens to be.
And you see it play out
also in domestic politics,
especially regarding things
like immigration. Right?
There's violence toward people who may
not share your particular political views
or share a different ethnicity or a
different religion or even a different sex
or sexual orientation.
So it plays out in many ways.
So we did one of these studies
where we actually looked at people's
dispositional level of fear. That is
the extent to which their temperament,
their genetic temperament,
it makes them more likely to react with
fear to particular stimuli than others.
And this is, this is different across
individuals from a baseline level,
meaning some people just have
higher levels of dispositional
fear to begin with.
Then other people do. What you find is
that those people who are more fearful,
um,
are more hostile to immigration.
Do object to multiculturalism,
don't like the notion of foreign trained
doctors want segregation and so on. Um,
and so what's actually happening is that
the reality is that fearful people are
conservative. It's not the
conservative people are
fearful, but fearful people, um,
you know,
become conservative.
So the other city we did is we actually
looked at the relationship between the
propensity for physical aggression
and the likelihood of supporting
interventionist foreign policy.
And making different kinds of decisions
on complex, um, moral and political tasks.
And I just wanted to show you what this,
what the scale looks like.
People respond one to six
from this is what I'm like to,
what I'm not really like. Um, and they're
basically physical aspects, you know,
you'd like to get in
physical fights and so on.
And people who rank higher on these
scores are much more likely to support
interventionist, foreign policy,
aggressive foreign policy.
These are some of the decisions.
We have the mic.
We also have the mic moral dilemmas about,
you know, you're on a ship that's over,
you know that Scott, too many
people it's about to turn overboard.
One of the people is very sick.
Do you toss him overboard or not?
And whether or not to give a vaccine that
you're not sure it's going to work to
a group of people.
And what you find is people who are much
more likely to respond with physical
aggression are more likely to engage and
support aggressive and interventions.
Foreign policy are much more
utilitarian in there. Um, uh,
moral decision making.
This is also true for men who are
physically stronger and women who are more
beautiful as assessed by other
people, not by themselves. Um,
so,
uh,
this is basically what I said the other
point to make is that there are real sex
differences in this.
Um,
men are more likely to endorse these
aggressive actions in general. Um,
and there's other factors that
do influence these outcomes
and these assessments,
the most important of which is really
education and also whether or not people
have fathers and whether or not
their fathers are involved with them.
To the extent that you
have absent fathers,
you get much more strong
endorsement of aggressive action,
much a stronger manifestation of
aggression and much more utilitarian moral
calculus. So support for, um,
processes that allow fathers to
stay with their families, uh,
has huge downstream
effects for their children.
And the final thing is just to say that
although these genetic factors I believe
really matter and account for
about half of what we're seeing,
these things always exist in a social
context in those social context.
Like whether or not you have a father,
like whether or not you have a good
education really affect the operation of
these genes and how they, uh,
come out in the real world.
And if any of you are more interested
in looking at this more deeply, um,
this is my edited volume on, um,
evolution, biology and politics,
which has a lot of summaries
from various different people,
including chapters on like, um, chimps,
chimps and how these things are
related to evolutionary, um, uh, uh,
impetus as well. So, um, I'm
gonna stop there and then, oh,
I don't have quite as much
time as I thought, but, um, uh,
have a discussion that I'd really like
with you with thoughts, questions,
comments, objections, concerns.
I saw that your, your studies,
um, worked with different groups,
different countries. There's some
Australian studies and you know,
the definition of liberal and
conservative in a, you know,
more socialist country might be different.
So do these patterns map on,
is that another area of research?
Yeah, that's a great
question. So, um, the,
we have data from lots of
different countries. Unfortunately,
the countries that we mostly have data
from our western industrialized countries,
so Australia, Denmark, Sweden, the United
States, you know, places like that.
But with those studies, what we've
been able to show is that, um,
these differences between liberals and
conservatives show up in every population
we've been able to look at across the
course of about 50 years that we've had
data that we've been able to look at.
What's important though is,
is part of the caveat of your question,
which is that again,
it's not Republicans and Democrats
in the narrow American sense.
From a world perspective,
Democrats and Republicans in the American
sense are like this far apart, right?
They're basically the same thing.
They're what we call Lockian liberals.
They believe in capitalism. By and large,
I mean Bernie, not so much, but, um,
you know, really, um, committed
to democratic principles,
capitalist economic structures,
particular kinds of notions
of tolerance and equality.
So they're different in
some domestic things,
but in kind of the world spectrum
from fascism to communism,
much more similar than they are different.
Um,
and when we look at these things in
other countries and around the world,
the ways in which they're stable are
really this kind of world political
spectrum from fascism, uh, on the
right to, um, communism on the,
on the left.
And I should have said that backwards,
but I'm trying to do it
this way. Um, so, um,
that's what matters is to just think
of ideology and a broader political
spectrum than just the
American political discourse.
And then you have real stability.
And I think part of what's going on here
is that you have a situation where from
an evolutionary standpoint,
you have some real universal
basic principles that
appear across every society
across time that basically have to do
with topics of survival and reproduction.
So think about sex and
reproduction issues. Um,
a resource allocation issues and issues
related to in group defense and outgroup
discrimination. The topic
may change given, you know,
the everyday topic may change from year
to year and from country to country so
that sometimes sex and reproduction
looks like fights over prostitution or
pornography in 18th century England.
But now it looks like a fight
over transgender bathrooms.
The specific topic may change,
but the underlying issue is about
regulating topics of sex and reproduction,
which are, you know, these
universal concerns. Um, from
an evolutionary standpoint.
Yeah. I'm also curious if you've, um, uh,
looked at work in a adult development.
Um, so also at Harvard, uh,
like Robert Keagan, uh, and, um,
so kind of building on the like,
so Piaget sort of identifying,
you'd have stages of child development.
Yeah. But as adults continue to grow,
I'm seeing the world, uh,
they're sort of perspectives,
continued growth through phases, seeing
the world in terms of greater complexity,
understanding their own motivation and
the motivation of others in greater
complexity.
Yeah.
Is it something that you've looked at in
terms of like the biological correlates?
Yeah. So, yes and no. Um, we've definitely
looked at the developmental piece. So,
um, especially one of the GS
that I've studied most, um,
Jewess Lee is this, um, a thing
called Mal monoamine oxidase.
And there's a particular kind of
polymorphism. It's, some people call it a,
some people call it a low activation,
however you want to call it, colloquially,
it's referred to as the warrior gene.
But I don't really like that
cause it's very pejorative. Uh,
it gets that terminology really from its
association with the Mallory population
in New Zealand.
And that is the only population in
the world where you get a much higher
percentage.
So in most of the world,
about a third of men show
this particular polymorphism.
And in New Zealand it's about two thirds.
You don't get it as much in women
because it's on the x chromosome.
And it's a recessive gene,
meaning since women have two copies,
it's very rare to find women who
have two copies of this polymorphism,
somewhere between eight and
12% of the population of women.
But it's really lower than that and about,
but in men it really is like 35%.
Um, now the reason I point to that gene
is it's the one that's been most closely
associated with, um, a susceptibility
to physical aggression.
And it's hugely effected by developmental
experiences. So, for example,
if you, um, have traumatic
early life events,
it makes it much more likely that the
gene will get activated or expressed and
you're much more likely to
then demonstrate physical
aggression later in your
life. And it matters when that
happens. So in this sense,
like Freud was right, zero
to five matters. But what
really matters is puberty,
so 11 to 15,
11 to 16,
and it's probably because there's a whole
cascade of hormones that get activated
around that period of time. So it's not
just the traumatic early life events,
it's how many you have and how severe
they are. So this is not like, you know,
I think of it as, it's not the Stanford
problem of like I got a B plus, right?
This is like my parents were in
jail, my brother died. Um, you know,
I grew up in a combat zone. These are
really severe developmental traumas.
Um,
and when you have a lot of them and
particularly when they happen at junctures
in time,
which is why I personally believe father
absence of puberty is particularly
problematic for potentiating violence
in certain populations. Um, I mean,
populations who have those kinds
of traumatic early life events,
that's the way in which developmental
aspects can really interact with these
genetic things to change the expression
of them. I don't usually like, um,
what they call snips, studies, you know,
single nucleotide protein or single, um,
you know, gene studies. But the stuff
around Mei was so well developed,
it's very clear that this,
you know,
probably about 10% of physical aggression
depending on whether or not you
believe the Dutch, um, knock outs.
There's a family. And in that,
that we study in,
in the Dutch population where the whole
family lacks this gene all together and
so they're really violent. There are
always causing arson and you know,
murder and all this kind of stuff.
And we do know from my snuck out studies
that this is really important. So,
um, those kinds of things
developmentally really matter.
The other piece that you add
about like, you know, the,
the Piaget and piece about understanding
yourself and understanding others and
perspective taking and how that matters.
I see that as the way in which various
aspects of education potentiate the
activation or the suppression of,
of not only genetic predispositions,
but also the environmental contingencies
that interact with and control them.
And that's why that's the place where
I think education really matters.
And when I say education here,
I don't mean just sitting in school,
I'm in the ways in which you train
your own brain, not through what you,
not just what you read, but in social
interaction with other people. Um,
particularly, I mean, if you
really believe these studies,
which I do has a lot to do
with eye contact and the
way in which you're able to
have, um, um, perspective taking,
which allows for the emotional
recognition of somebody else's experience.
So it's about learning empathy and then
it can change the ways in particular in
which you see expressions of violence,
but other characteristics as well.
You had mentioned that in the Mri scan
there was sort of a indication towards a
reaction of fear towards risk
on the conservative side.
And then you've mentioned
discussed on the liberal side. Um,
how do you see that manifest in
political views on the liberal side?
I think it's not the only emotion. I
mean, I want to start out by saying that,
but the way that I see it,
and sometimes I see it manifesting as
discussed and sometimes I see it as
manifesting as contempt.
So it's this kind of, um,
it's not just that the
other side is misguided,
but the other side is
somehow morally corrupt,
morally irresponsible.
Um,
the other thing I should say about the
insula is it's not just about disgust.
It also is about holding simultaneous
holding contradictory ideas
simultaneously.
So it's about complexity of thought.
And I do think that there's
lots of additional evidence
that shows that liberals
in general, um, uh,
tend to entertain a lot
more complexity of thought.
And that's not always necessarily a
good thing because what happens with
complexity of thought is you can
paralyze yourself, right? Like, well,
it could be this or it could be that,
or there's 18 other ways in which the
sub for, you know, the subtle form of it.
I mean,
you can see a lot of it in the debate.
She know where Hillary would be like,
and then there's point a and 0.8
has three sub points, you know, and,
and Trump would be like, it's sad, right?
So there's this very different kind of,
um, yeah, it's very, very different kinds
of approaches. So I want to say that,
that the insula has this other piece of,
but the way that I see the disgust coming
out is the unwillingness to see the
other side or the other person as,
um,
a a moral being worthy of consideration
in the same way as another liberal.
Right. Um, so that there's this, um,
I'm not going to call it a failure of
empathy because it's not really about
empathy. It's really more about,
um, subject object to, right.
So the way that I saw it in this last
election was a real disregard for class
considerations.
You know,
where you wouldn't see liberals
talking a lot about poor people.
So much as they were talking about
race and gender and sexuality,
you weren't hearing a lot about the
white working class who is suffering. Um,
not just from poverty,
but from, um, you know,
a whole bunch of other,
um,
cultural upheavals that felt real to them.
And because liberals didn't
consider that they should be real,
they weren't going to
be considered as much.
And I think that that's what ended up
biting us, you know, biting the, um, uh,
liberal, uh, supporters in the, but, um,
when that group really rose up and said,
I don't care that I'm
hurting my own self interest,
I just want to make sure
that you get hurt too. Right.
I'm going to take you down with me.
And I think that there's, there's that,
that failure of connection
and, and, um, um, uh,
equivalents of,
uh,
moral consideration of the other as a
subject and not just an object that is
what you see play out. I don't see
that as much on the conservative side,
but the fear thing is just activated.
I mean,
the Republican convention was like a
festival of fear. Everything was like,
be scared and then be more scared
and be more scared than that.
And then there's these other
things you thought about,
you know, like it was sort of a hysterical
fear. Um, and that was very, very,
very activated. And so that, that
was the way I saw it on both sides.
I was wondering if you had done any
research or had any thoughts on people who
find themselves politically opposed
to their parents and the rest of their
family?
Yeah, so, um, that's the most obvious
thing when you think about genetics. Like,
well, if I'm not like my parents, then
how can I, you know, be like this.
And the way I think about is a friend of
mine who had a kid who had red hair and
was convinced that his wife had cheated.
And so he went out and forced her to
get a DNA test on the kid and, um,
it causes a divorce. And then as soon as
his mom came to help take care of them,
cause the divorce was happening,
she go on and look at the kid and said,
oh my God,
that looks just like my grandfather.
Right. And what happened was he
had never known his grandfather,
but she had known the grandfather.
And so things skip generations.
It's true not just with
hair color and eye color,
but it's true with political ideology,
right? So we're not just our parents,
we are the sum of all of our
ancestors across multiple generations.
And so, um, if we're not like our parents,
that doesn't necessarily mean that
there isn't a genetic component.
And part of how we know this is that
people look much more like their parents
till they leave the house.
And I think that that's because there's
a lot of socialization going on in the
house. It's not okay to not be what the
parents are, but once you go to college,
what you see is people
shifting dramatically and
they're actually shifting back
more toward their genetic predisposition.
And it's because, you know,
the sort of the,
the,
the tamping socialization of the household
gets lifted and then you are what you
are.
And some of that is your parents,
but your parents aren't just your
parents and your grandparents or great
grandparents or great grip, you know,
and, and on back on through, you know,
multiple history and
these things have very,
very long history is 13% of the men on
the planet are direct descendants of
Ganga con.
Right?
I mean there's these really long
histories of particular kind of, um,
high reproductive, you
know, um, our strategy,
reproductive males.
Yes.
Oh,
going back to the question or the
observation of the emotions of let's say
contempt or, um, discussed, uh,
influencing or informing the,
the liberal perspective and fear,
primarily informing the conservative,
um,
imagine let's say a liberal work to
overcome those negative emotions and,
and really empathize and try to
understand the other point of view and,
and rise above it to let's say almost
a Buddhist or like what I mentioned the
Dalai Lama. Oh. Might be able to do, um,
when the result then still be
very liberal. I mean, isn't,
aren't the qualities of empathy and
understanding and compassion. Um,
what I'm getting at is I, I wonder
if I heard the hint of a, of a,
of an equivalents or positive
equivalents that, you know,
there's this negative thing
on the conservative side
and this negative thing on
the liberal side.
And I can imagine that it's attractive
to try to phrase things that way too.
You know, when the point of view
of trying to appear neutral,
but it seems that if we were to extend
this idea of just getting rid of the
negative emotions altogether,
get rid of getting rid of the contempt
or the disgust and try to have
understanding where does that
lead politically? [inaudible]
okay. So I'm, I'm going to answer your
question the way I think about it,
which may not actually be what you mean.
Um,
so the way I think about these things is
from an evolutionary standpoint, and, um,
no society could exist if
we were just all liberals.
And the reason for that is that we'd
get predated by other people, right?
There's always going to be
a few psychopaths out there,
even if you just understand that as
mutations of random stuff from nuclear
fallout or whatever.
Right?
So if we want to protect ourselves
from the environment, from animals,
from other people,
we always need some number
of conservatives who are
going to be, you know,
lack of anything else really
good at combat, right?
Protecting the Ingroup outgroup
from our group. Um, attacks.
No,
similarly,
no society could exist who is just
conservative because then there'd be no
cooperation. Nobody to
build houses, organizations,
institutions, Google. Right. The,
it wouldn't exist. So you need
both of them. The problem is,
is how to get that to happen
in concert. Um, I personally,
there's a big debate about
this in the literature,
but I believe that we learn to cooperate
because we needed to engage in conflict
more effectively.
Combat is what taught people to cooperate.
In order to have effective combat against
the outgroup, you have to be really,
really good at in group cooperation.
Those things happen together
in genetic senses. What's
that co what? What's that?
What that is called is
frequency dependent selection.
You have two different traits or n number,
different traits that have to remain
stable in the population over time or, um,
the overall society falls apart.
If you have a trait that's so successful,
it converges to universality.
Think about the fact that when you're
really scared, your vision gets better,
your hearing gets Burke better.
That's a trait that's so,
that's so successful in the potentiating,
the survival of its possessors
that it converges to universality.
That's never going to happen with liberals
and conservatives because you need
both.
The problem has happened now is because
our societies are way bigger than how we
were. We grew up, right?
We grew up in communities of 150 people
where we knew everybody we could tell
who was cheating the system, we could
sanction who was cheating the system.
But we now have to apply that psychology
that's really built on 150 people to
320 million people.
And so all of a sudden that psychology
gets hijacked and thinks that the only
way we're gonna survive as if we destroy
all conservatives are if we destroy all
liberals, depending on where
we go, that's not gonna work.
What in my view is most likely to be
successful is to find ways in which we
joined together.
Liberals and conservatives for
a larger goal like the nation,
right?
You can see it in the military,
you can see it in some
places where you know,
you can see it in football
teams where race doesn't matter,
where ideology doesn't matter.
What matters is the particular
mission or the particular goal. Um,
and how we get there to a place of
tolerance and a place of recognizing the
value of each side I
think is a real challenge.
And I wish I knew how to get there.
And I'm working with some people
both politically as well as, um,
you know, academically to try
and think about ways to do that.
But it's a challenge for sure.
And I agree with you.
I think the Buddhist perspective
is the right perspective.
The problem is selling that perspective.
To a majority Christian country.
So some countries seem to tend
more conservative over time.
And you mentioned that the u s you know,
actually was liberal on
the overall spectrum. Yeah.
But there significant genetic differences.
I mean,
you could and you could imagine that
being the case because the US is a nation
of immigrants.
So, um, I, the answer,
I'm going to give you a sort of
half assed, which is that, um,
we don't have good genetic studies
of say Middle Eastern populations,
partly because we don't get in
there and do those populations.
So I don't know whether there's
genetic differences. Well,
we do have are these world value surveys
where you go around and ask people
about their attitudes and
you get dramatic differences,
especially on things related
to sex and reproduction.
So things like whether or
not homosexuality is okay,
whether or not it's okay for women to
be independent financially or socially,
whether or not men or women should have
control of reproduction. Those things,
you get dramatic differences. The most
liberal countries are always Scandinavian,
right?
It's always like Sweden and Norway and
Denmark and the US is actually not that
high. They are when you think
about it, because like for example,
there's still this thing and the United
States where most people kind of think
it's best if you get married
before you have kids.
The Scandinavians got rid of that
a long time ago, you know, um,
the worst countries by far always
the Middle Eastern countries. Um,
and so what that, how much of that is
socialized and how much of it is genetic?
We don't know cause I,
we haven't done the genetic work.
I will say that based
on the stuff you know,
that I've done with mio and the work that
I've seen done with women who survived
the family.
So there's a big study done with women
who survived the famine in 1944, nine,
9:43 AM nine 43 in the Netherlands.
And they've tracked their children now
through two generations because it was a
terrible famine. And their children
tended to be really underweight.
And what they find is that those children
are differentially susceptible to
diabetes and being overweight
two generations later
because of huge changes in
genetic expression that allowed their
mothers to survive in a famine allowed
them to survive at birth.
But then the minute you look at a Reese's
peanut butter cup, you have diabetes,
right?
I mean,
it's this thing that that has really good
survival advantage and then costs and
an environment of abundance,
right?
So if you look at those studies and you
think about the way that plays out, uh,
with things like mio,
I think if you have environments where
women are pregnant in conditions of
incredible deprivation, famine, war,
violence, they're raped, whatever,
and then they grow up,
those kids then grow up in environments
where most of their relatives are killed.
They, they're in constant bombing.
I mean, think about Syria.
It's going to cause the expression of
all those genes to get activated toward
higher levels of violence.
I think you're going to get what you see,
which is the intergenerational transfer
of only understanding violence as
appropriate conflict resolution.
So there's both social elements
of it and biological elements.
And I suspect that's what's going on.
So like,
my whole thing is you want to change
the outcome in the Middle East.
Maternal mount, you know,
maternal nutrition. Start
giving these people vitamins,
start getting them into safe
environments when they're pregnant.
Like that's the thing,
what you should do.
And everybody in the u s government
looks to me like I'm on drugs like,
and what drug are you taking? You know?
Um, because they just think it's crazy.
But I do think that that's how,
that's the place you could intervene to
change it and it would be acceptable and
nobody minds being helped, right?
I mean, in that way. Um, so,
uh, but it's very hard to
convince people that that's the,
that's the right approach. It's
Wacky, right? It's also true, but, um,
that doesn't change the receptivity.
Thank you very much for speaking
with us today. Well, um,
hopes he have you back as your
research continues. Thank you.
[inaudible].